Mufasa, you there?
>> Hello.
>> There we go.
>> Yeah.
>> There we go. There we go, man. So,
question, Mufasa, would you trust a
religion with corrupt description, man?
>> No, I wouldn't.
>> Good. Okay, that's a I wouldn't either,
honestly. That's that's a that's a good
thing. Um, Torah, the Torah was revealed
by Allah. You would agree?
>> Yeah, he's the source of the Torah.
>> And the Gospel as well and the Zabor,
were those also revealed by Allah? You
would agree?
>> Muas, are you good?
>> Yeah, sorry, I had it called. No
worries. I asked about I asked the same
thing about the the gospel and the uh
and the uh psalms. You believe that
those were also revealed by Allah?
>> Yes, I believe they all they all come
from the same divine source.
>> Okay. Do you believe that they got
corrupted?
>> Yeah, I believe um part of it got
corrupted. Yeah.
>> Okay. Um what about the Quran?
Obviously, you believe that was revealed
by Allah?
>> Whether by whether by transmission or by
whether by word or by by writing some of
them. Yeah.
>> Okay. And what about the Quran? Do you
believe the Quran is well revealed by
Allah? Do you believe parts of that got
corrupted or do you believe that it's
fully intact?
>> I believe the Quran is intact.
>> Okay. Um so we got the Torah, Psalms,
the Gospel,
and the Quran. Four books of Allah. Um
and out of the four books, three of them
got corrupted. So you follow a religion
with corrupted scripture and therefore
Islam is untrustworthy.
>> Call me again, please.
>> Are you are you busy right now, man? You
want to come back later?
>> No, it's fine. It's okay now. We can we
can talk.
>> Okay. So, so you you said that the
Torah, the Psalms, the Gospel, those
three got corrupted, but the Quran is
still intact. So, three out of four of
Allah's books got corrupted. And so
therefore, you follow a religion with
corrupted scripture and Islam is not
trustworthy.
>> That's that doesn't really follow. And
and it's for the simple reason that the
the message is not a message that is
proportional to each messenger like you
can say four books and well if four
divided by 100 it's 25 even to each like
each messenger came with a pieces of the
puzzle whenever a messenger came it came
with a complete
>> so you have like
>> so you have 25%
>> yeah so you have 25% of your religion
really you're missing the other you're
missing
>> that would be the case if we the script
the scripture has been you know directly
made proportional to each messenger to
each prophet that brought it right but
that is not the case it's not like each
messenger came with 25% of the truth
>> oh it's not like that
>> right it's every messenger came of the
truth
>> okay and so you're saying that these
messages got corrupted and so within
your religion you have corrupted
scripture and you said that you wouldn't
follow a religion with corruption
>> it's just reinforced whenever so
whenever a message came it is
reinforcing the one that has been
corrupted so it is coming like a brand
new packaged message like it is complete
in all its sense.
>> No, it's not.
>> It's a 100% message.
>> No, it's not at all. It doesn't. It
doesn't tell you what the angel is or
>> what the Torah is or it doesn't tell
you. Does the Quran say um we have
revealed to you just as we revealed to
the prophet before you?
>> Yes. But he's revealed something
different.
>> Does it also say
>> do do you agree do you agree? Do you do
you agree that the Quran is different
from the angel, the Torah and the
Psalms? Yeah, you can say there is
difference in some um some of the
stories being given. But when it comes
to the centric or the centralized
message itself like worshiping one god
and that one god has sent messengers
over a period of time and also those
messengers were and also those things
were corrupted that he used to
communicate with
>> those those messages were corrupted.
Those messages were corrupted.
>> Yes, those messages.
>> So you follow a religion.
>> It was fragmented. Mufasa, you follow a
religion that has corrupted scripture.
You said that you wouldn't do that, but
you're doing it.
>> Yeah, but I have the Quran, which is
100%. It's not
>> I got you. The the Quran is fully intact
and preserved. The other three
scriptures that came before the Quran
are corrupted and not intact. And so
therefore, within your religion, you
only have one book that has been
preserved so far, while the others have
been corrupted. And you said that you
would not trust a religion that has
corrupted scripture. So you have you
have three corrupted scriptures. Only
one of them is good out of the four.
>> So So Islam the religion Islam is not
based on those other scriptures as
Muslims. The Quran is enough for us. The
Quran and the Sunnah.
>> That's not true at all. Accordingly,
>> it is enough for us.
>> Wait, wait, hold on. Uh can can you
Okay. Is is it can you be a Muslim and
reject the Torah, Gospel, and Psalms?
>> No, it's not about rejecting them. We So
>> that's not what I asked, brother.
Please, please, if you divine, if you
can answer the question, if you can
answer the question, can you
>> be a Muslim and reject?
>> I'm sorry.
>> No, you can't reject them. Thank you.
And let me explain how. Right.
>> Well, I I'll let you I'll let you don't
have to explain how. It's it's really
simple.
>> You said that you as a Muslim, the Quran
and the Sunna, that's all you need.
That's enough for you. However, by your
own admission, you cannot reject the
previous scriptures and still be a
Muslim. So, the Quran and Sunnah are not
enough for you. You
>> so,
>> you have to believe in the other
scriptures.
>> Reject them in the reject them in the
sense saying that they were not revealed
or they were not sent by God, right?
>> No,
>> we accept that God sent previous one
second. One second. Let me finish. Go
ahead.
>> We accept that God sent previous. This
is this is the explanation given by the
scholars. This is the explanation that
we can find in the which we can find by
the
and even by the prophet. We have we have
an authentic where I think it was um who
brought a scripture to the prophet and
then the prophet said why are you
bringing this to me for I tell you
verily that even if Moses was alive
today he will follow me.
>> What does that have to do with the idea
that you can reject the previous
scriptures? You don't have to believe in
them currently, but you only got you you
can only believe in the Quran and you're
good to go. Even Muhammad says that when
he when they the Jews came to him, he
asked them for the Torah. What does your
Torah say? Bring your Torah. That's what
you're going to do. Even your Quran
says, why do they come to you when they
have the Torah in which Allah's
judgments are in? Let the people of the
gospel judge by what Allah is revealed
therein. We believe in what was revealed
to you and what was revealed to us. So
according to Muhammad, he currently
believes. Can you finish please?
>> According to Muhammad, you have to
currently believe in the revelations of
Allah. But you're saying that you don't
have to believe in the revelations of
Allah. So do you have something where
Muhammad says that you don't have to
believe in the current revelation of
Allah like the previous ones?
>> Did I say
so? I think you have to you haven't
really delve into Islamic theology. You
only read the Quran.
>> Saying that doesn't help me. Saying that
doesn't help me. Do you have something?
Do you have something from Muhammad
Mufasa? That's where Muhammad says that
you no longer have to believe in the
Torah, Gospel or Psalms in his current
time.
>> Yeah, we have an authenticity. The
prophet said, "If the people of the book
tell you anything, don't deny them.
Neither do you believe them." Right.
>> Why?
>> Just say, just say.
>> Uhhuh.
>> Yes. Because they have
>> No. No. Finish it. Finish it. Finish it.
>> Finish it.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Because they have corrupted
scriptures. Just say it. Let me finish.
Let me finish.
>> Finish what he said, please.
>> Let me finish.
>> All right. Go ahead. We're listening.
Just say it.
>> I'm already giving you the ending.
>> Oh my gosh. Hey, Mufasa. Look, brother.
>> Listen. You You have a golden
opportunity right now. There's a lot of
people watching on both platforms. You
have a golden opportunity right now to
be honest.
>> Let me bring
>> finish what Muhammad said before I
>> cuz he was just about to say my father
do this all the time. Just just lying,
man. For no reason, dude. You lied for
no reason. It's so funny because
I
>> I'll do it for you. I'll finish it for
you. He says, "Say rather, we believe in
what was revealed to us and what was
revealed to you." Correct.
>> Yes.
>> Okay.
>> Precisely. So, what was revealed?
>> So, Mua, according to Muhammad, are you
ordered to believe in the Hold on.
Excuse me. Hold on. Mafasa, are you
ordered according to the hadith by
Muhammad
>> to believe in the revelations that the
Jews and Christians have with them?
>> Yes. To believe in it in this in the
form of its divine source. Right. We
believe that it is a revelation. One
second. One second. Let me one second.
One second. Give me my opportunity to
>> We believe in Let me let me finish. We
believe in their divine origin, right?
like the divine origin of those books.
We believe in the divine origin, but we
don't believe in its transmission that
has been given by
>> you could do you can do whatever you
want. That's the opposite of what
Muhammad says. And that's okay.
>> So, so what so what you have what you
have is you have you only believe in the
Quran, Mufasa. You only believe in the
Quran. You reject the other books, which
is what Muhammad tells you not to do.
And then you're still following a
religion that's full of corrupted
scripture.
>> Out of your four books, out of your four
books, three, the Torah, the Gospel, the
Psalms got corrupted. You follow a
religion that's untrustworthy, which is
something you said you would not do. You
would not follow a religion would
corrupt the scripture.
>> Do we deny Do we deny its divine origin?
>> Amen.
>> Do we deny their divine origin?
>> I appreciate it, man. That's enough for
you.
>> It's a simple question.
>> It is a simple question. Go go go go go
ahead and continue that simple question
in the audience.
>> Man,
>> I love trying to lie
>> confident they are in baking themselves,
bro. The pure the pure cope after they
answer the question is insane, bro. It's
just like self. It's like you put a
hamster on a wheel, bro.
>> Let them go.
>> Imagine going to a hadith. Dude, you got
a you got too much going on over there.
>> Imagine get off my stage, you numb
digger. Yeah,
>> imagine going through aith saying that
yeah, in this hadith Muhammad tells us
not to believe in the current scriptures
when he literally says believe in their
current scriptures. Just don't believe
what they say.
>> The hadith he quoted literally says
believe in what they have.
>> Like but that's but that that that was
the that was the the beginning of the
double talk.
>> Yeah.
>> Right. Don't don't don't believe what
they tell you, but don't disbelieve what
they tell you. Just say you believe what
was given to us and what was given to
you.
>> What Muhammad, bro, what you doing, bro?
What we doing, Muhammad? What we doing,
man? We What we doing, bro? And Muhammad
just like, yes, it's all it's all it's
all it's all the Quran.
>> It's all the Quran.
>> All of it. Ain't that what they said
when they was trying to figure out the
differences? And he's saying this and
he's saying that. Which one is true? All
of it.
>> All of it.
>> Get out of my face, man. Go find me a
wife.
Shoot. All right. Before uh this next
guest speaks, I want to read some super
chats. One second, my brother.
>> Okay.
>> So, we got uh we got H D Melo says, "I'm
a 40-year-old truck overnight driver.
Hall all over New England and just
wanted to let you know that I drive all
night listening to you. God bless."
Thank you so much, brother. That means
everything, man. That's awesome. We got
JGC who says, "You should do a video
montage of all the Muslims accepting
Christ on your liveream." Yeah, we do
those every now and then. We got Sparkly
says, "The Numb Digger tree,
>> oh man,
>> has already begun.
>> We about to get so many variations of
Num Digger, bro. It's It's going to be a
$2 super chat every time you go live,
bro.
>> The Numb Digot tree has already begun."
Oh, Andrew Michael says, "A lot of us
speak to Muslim friends dayto-day. I It
would be great to have common questions
and answers in a PDF. Would you consider
making one accessible? I'll pay $200 for
your time creating it." Thanks. But uh I
don't Man, we we we got some Dude,
answeringIislam.org
has already did all done all of this.
Answeringislam.org or has the common
objections that Muslims bring up,
>> the answers to these objections, how you
can flip the tables on them.
Answeringislam.org
has it all. The work has already been
done, guys, indepth. Okay. Yep.
>> So, go to answeringislam.org
and trust me, you everything you need is
right there. Okay. Yeah. We're not uh
we're not central Dawa, man. We don't
sell combat kits, man. Yeah, you know
it's all it's all out there for free.
>> Yeah, the truth.
>> All right, the true watchman of God
says, "Brother, can we get can we just
get a shout out for our brother in
Christ, Soldier for Christ? This brother
is the future of street preaching, Holy
Spirit, firefilled boldness, and
conviction." Yeah, man. I made a a
community post about that, brother. But
yeah, if you guys aren't following
Soldier for Christ, man, go ahead and
follow Soldier 4 with the number four
for Christ. Go ahead and subscribe to
his channel and support him. Young guy
on fire before the Lord. All right. Are
you ready?
>> I'll let you know when I'm ready, bro.
>> All right.
>> Joe Ro says, "She chef logic and life
serving up Michelle and star meals from
junk." God bless you,
>> dude. No,
>> no, no. Come on, man.
>> It's not Michelle. You got too many
people. You got too many people
watching.
>> Is it not Michelle?
>> No.
>> What is it?
>> Michelin.
>> It's not Michelle.
>> No, dude. Michelin, you are you lucky
your live. You lucky you just started
your live, bro. Bro, we already got
1,500 people in here.
>> Yeah, you lucky we ain't 3,000.
>> It's not It's not m It's not Michelle.
>> Absolutely not.
>> That sounds way better than Michelin.
You said Michelin Michelin star chef.
>> That sounds way better than Michelle,
bro. I ain't going to lie,
>> sweetheart. Okay, here we go.
>> I'm sorry, guest. He can't read. So,
>> I am reading. I'm just My my my dialect
is different. That's all.
>> Oh,
okay. I see what you did there. Is it
Michellein or Michelin?
>> Oh my. It's Michelin.
>> Yeah, like the tires.
>> Go go go to your room.
>> We're gonna we're going to talk about
this.
>> Wow.
>> Hey, open up your Quran. Go to chapter
4:34 for me. Okay, sweetheart.
>> And just wait for him. Just wait.
>> Wow.
>> Go to the
>> Hey. Hey.
>> And she knows the deal.
>> Oh, she can't even hear me. She can't
hear.
>> Sorry. Sorry, Granny. Sorry, Granny.
Christina's going to have to she's going
to have to we're going to have to visit
some Quran verses cuz she just
embarrassed me here live in front of all
these people. Not
>> we going to have to read Quran tonight.
>> We going to have to recite.
>> We're going to have to recite tonight.
You know what I'm saying? We got to
recite a couple couple that reminder.
>> How you doing?
>> I'm good.
>> Hello.
>> I'm good, bro.
>> Oh man. Oh, it was nice flicking you
last one. It was so good. I had to come
back again.
>> Oh yeah. when you admitted that there
were two creators in Islam. Nice. Yeah,
you did good. You did good in Acts.
>> Admitted. Yeah. Okay. Okay. Even if I
were to grant you that. Okay. Let's
Let's grant you that for a second.
>> You don't got to grant me nothing. Hold
on. Hold on.
>> It's a new day. It's a new day.
>> Hold on. Hold on.
>> How did he create? How did he create?
>> It's a new day. Habibi.
>> We have a new We have a new question
today. We have a different question.
>> I'll start. I I Let's start with today's
>> We have
>> I'll bake you in that one, too.
>> Actually, since you baked me last time,
Abdul, Abdul, if you want to stay on
here long, you got to relax, bro. You're
You're already hyped.
>> You baked me last time, so now you got
to bake my big bro. All right.
>> So, can can you bake him?
>> Who's your big bro?
>> Him.
>> That guy.
>> Yep. Reacts, bro.
>> Yeah. I don't know.
>> Hey, that is kind of right. I ain't
going to lie. I'll be watching my lines
back like
>> come on.
>> I'll be watching my lines back. I'll be
like, "Okay, I could I could have cut
that a little short. I could have cut I
could have cut the rant a little short."
You know, I'm working on it. Working on
me.
>> I'm still Did you call him Yap React?
>> Yeah.
>> Is that what you called him?
>> Abdu.
>> All right. Okay. So So your main
argument is saying that you should
>> He has He has a He has a question, bro.
He has a question, bro. Oh, yeah. Sure.
Why not? Go ahead.
>> Yeah. What? So, uh, would you follow a
religion with corrupted scripture?
>> Oh my god. Uh, no.
>> All right, cool. So, in your religion,
how many scriptures were revealed?
>> Yeah, brother. I I've seen the last
guest. I've been listening. I already
know what you're going to say. Okay. So,
listen.
>> So,
>> is the answer yes? So So, is the answer
still no?
>> Uh, it's it's still no. And I'll explain
why.
>> Okay. So, hold on. You can't just Hold
on. You can't just jump ahead. Don't
don't jump it. Don't jump it, man. So,
how many books were revealed in your
religion? How many of them are
corrupted? How many of them aren't?
>> Uh, well, the Quran talks about the
Torah, the Psalms, the Gospel, and the
Quran itself. So,
>> the Quran's one the Quran's one of the
corrupted ones.
>> No, the Quran. No, those are the books
that are mentioned in the Quran.
>> Okay. Which ones are corrupted and which
ones aren't?
>> Well, they are all of them were
originally not corrupted, but they were
uh three of them, I believe. the main uh
which is psalms, Torah and the Bible I
believe in.
>> Cool. All right. Cool. So three Okay. So
three out of four scriptures in Islam
have been corrupted. So that means that
within your religion you have three sets
of corrupted scriptures by your own
admission, right? You said yes.
>> Oh, I I you know. So, so by your own
admission, you have three sets of
scriptures
that are corrupted within your religion.
>> Yeah. But did you know that those three
sets of scriptures
>> I would just before you answer that? I'm
going to answer
before you build trust me. You're going
to have your turn to to clear it all and
clean it all up later. Mhm.
>> So by your admission within Islam you
have three sets of corrupted scripture.
>> Yes. That were corrupted by men.
>> All right. So within the religion of
Islam you have majority within within
the religion of Islam
>> the majority of Allah's scriptures that
he revealed has been corrupted.
>> Meaning within your religion you have
majority corrupted scripture. on a taco.
>> I was just like a yes or no really
quick.
>> Uh, no. Because it comes with
explanation.
>> Okay. So, I'm confused now. Do you
follow it?
>> If if I may, can I speak?
>> I got you. But sometimes the problem is
is you guys don't want to
>> like It's easy with the other guy
talking.
>> If you if you understand for a second,
it's hard for me to allow you to just
filibuster without concluding. I
>> Your answer is no. The answer is
>> we're all confused. Okay. So, Okay. So
the answer is no. That the majority of
Allah's scriptures that was revealed
were corrupted. The answer is no. When
three sets out of one have been cor I
mean three sets out of four have been
corrupted. Do you know what majority
means?
>> That doesn't mean Islam is false. That's
the thing.
>> I'm not asking if Islam is false right
now. That's what that's what the prompt
says.
>> The prompt says Islam is untrustworthy.
>> Same same thing if you want to come out.
>> That would make it false. But you have
to answer questions properly first. You
I don't even know if you know what
majority means. Is three scriptures out
of if three scriptures out of four
revealed are corrupted? Three. Is the
majority of your scriptures revealed
corrupted?
>> Do you want to be sure? Sure. Just just
so we can move on. Sure.
>> Okay. Thank you. So earlier you said you
wouldn't follow a religion with
corrupted scriptures. Can you switch
that now and say you do follow a
religion with corrupted scriptures and
on top of that the majority of your
scriptures in your religion are
corrupted? So can we can we can we tell
the truth now?
>> Can I talk, bro? Like I swear it's just
>> this is your time to speak. This is your
turn to speak right after you say this.
>> So is it so so can we tell the truth?
>> So hard to like have a conversation with
brother. Can I speak?
>> I'm actually being very very patient
with you. This is it. Listen, this is
your floor to speak after you answer the
question honestly. We just established
what is and what isn't within your
religion in regards to corrupted
scripture. Now, can you be honest? Now,
>> I don't believe in Hold on. Hold on. My
religion follows the Quran. It does not
follow these scriptures. Okay.
>> But within your religion, you have
corrupted scripture
>> of my religion. They are
>> But within your religion, you
>> my religion. You understand?
>> Okay. Great. But within your religion
say within your religion because it's
not part they were built upon my
religion.
>> Are these Did Allah reveal Did Allah
reveal the scriptures?
>> Yes.
>> So are they Allah's scriptures? Okay. So
are they Allah's scriptures?
>> Yes. Revealed to prophets
>> under the religion of Islam. Right.
Under the religion of Islam, right?
>> I'm sure.
>> Okay. So these are your religious
scriptures within Islam that have been
corrupted. So the majority of your
scriptures revealed in your religion
have been corrupted. So please be
honest. You do follow a religion with
corrupted scripture. So let's ask the
question again. Do you?
>> No.
>> I mean if if you're going to have this
one side argument, I'll just leave.
>> It's your turn to speak.
>> You just hear people talk though. You
just like
>> It's your turn. It's your turn to speak,
dude.
>> The first thing The first I'm not
crying. You just like to hear yourself.
>> He's a Muslim, man. They you know victim
mode. You got to you got to go victim.
>> It's not a victim mode. You guys are
just hardheaded. I like to talk to
yourselves. If I if I can explain but
without nice. So first Allah did not um
the Torah, the songs in the gospel.
Number one, Allah did not promise to
preserve them. Okay. It's talking about
the Quran. Okay. And there's also a
verse in the Are you just not going to
listen?
>> Sorry, we're just just cleaning up
around
>> like these are these are these these are
the same people that are getting cooked
by freaking what's his name? Just just
we're just helping We're just helping
you clean up. We're just helping you
clean it up a bit. Logic. Huh? Logic.
Huh? Logic. Throw that in here.
>> There we go. You got it. You got it.
>> I got it. I got it. I got it.
>> Why are you so weird?
>> Got it, man.
>> Anything but actually engaging in a
debate. That's crazy as hosts, by the
way.
>> Go ahead, man. We We already swept it up
for you, man. So, just go ahead and
pick.
>> Okay. So, Muslim. Okay. Hold on. Hold
on. Hold on. Okay. So in in verse 159 it
says indeed it is we who sent down the
reminder which is the Quran and indeed
we will guard it. Okay. So the Quran is
talking about like uh God is talking
about the Quran. Okay. We are the ones
that sent down the scripture. Okay. Now
the earlier scriptures the Torah, the
Psalms and the Gospel which was revealed
to David, Moses and Jesus. Right? Allah
did not promise to preserve them. When
it says we preserve the word of God,
we're talking only specifically about
the Quran. That's why it exists today.
Okay. Now, here's the thing. In verse
279, it says, "So, woe to those who
write the scripture with their own
hands, then say this is from Allah in
order to exchange it for a small price."
It's talking about your books. Okay?
Your books, the Bible, the the Torah,
the the the what's it called? The the
Psalms. It's talking about
>> I thought those were Allah's books.
>> Okay.
>> I thought those were Allah's book. I
thought those were Allah's books.
>> Changed by man. They are changed by man.
Exactly. And and and Allah did not
promise to preserve those books. Okay.
So the final message pretty much is
meant for all times. Now when it comes
to the hadith that you mentioned was
there because you mentioned Allah. You
mentioned a lot. Let's go ahead and
discuss. So um
>> what's there to discuss? There's verses
for you.
>> So no I we got you. So according to
everything you laid out, the Quran is
the only book that Allah promised to
preserve. His other books, he allowed
them to get corrupted. He didn't promise
to preserve those. So he has a track
record of letting his books get
corrupted except for one. Is that right?
>> Yeah. But also it comes with common
sense that people memorize them.
>> I got you. So if I I used this example
the last time. If there's a babysitter,
>> he gave humans free will.
>> I got you. If there's a babysitter who
um got got hired four times, right? This
babysitter got hired four times and in
in uh three in her first three times
that she got hired.
>> This isn't Let me finish. Let me finish.
>> Talking about God.
>> Abdul, if you can just relax, maybe you
might it might click for you. If um if
this babysitter for the first three
times um doesn't watch the kids
properly, she doesn't pick up the kids
from school, she doesn't feed them, um
they end up getting hurt on her watch,
getting lost on her watch in these first
three jobs. But in the fourth job, she
does perfectly fine. And in fact, she
never said that she was actually going
to do a great job those first three
times. She But she promised she would do
a great job watching the babies this
fourth time
>> and therefore she has a bad track
record. That's So does she have a bad
track record?
>> Huh?
>> Does she have a bad track record?
>> You're comparing a babysitter with the
girl.
>> I just want to know if she has a bad
track record. Yes or no?
>> You're comparing the babysitter with
>> I just want to know if she has a bad
track record. Yes or no?
>> I don't care about personal analogies.
>> That's I'm I'm happy you don't care, but
I just would like an answer. They don't
mean anything.
>> Oh, right. That's it's irrelevant all of
a sudden, right? As soon as it beats his
law.
>> Yeah. Sure.
>> Does she have a bad track? Yes or no?
>> Sure.
>> Also, so she has a bad track. We
>> can move on cuz you So, with this being
said, we can see very obviously that
this babysitter has a bad track record
even though she got her last one right,
her last job. Right. Now, my question to
you is this. with Allah having three
revelations that he revealed, Torah,
Psalms, and Gospel. He allowed those to
get manipulated, distorted, and
corrupted. But he said that he will
protect the last one and intentionally
protected the last one. Does Allah have
a good track record or a bad track
record of preserving his scriptures?
>> Who are you to judge if God has a good
or bad track record?
>> Shake.
>> Huh?
>> I'm a shake.
>> Who are you to Who are you to judge
that?
Trust me, this isn't God. If you could
just answer the question,
>> brother. It literally says it in the
scripture though.
>> If you could if you if you could just
answer the question, that'd be fine.
>> Huh?
>> So, does Allah have a good track record
or a bad track record?
>> No. No. No. No. No.
>> Which one is it?
>> Absolutely no.
>> I said no. It's a two-word answer.
>> It's not a It's not a no. It's a
>> It's no
>> No. What?
>> It's No.
>> No.
Does he have That's why
>> does he have a good track record of
preserving his scripture or does he have
a bad track record of preserving his
scripture?
>> It's the people who change them. It
isn't God who changed them.
>> I'll give you one last chance.
>> God reveals them.
>> Does he have a good track record of
preserving and protecting his books or
does he have a bad track record?
>> That's not a good argument, dear God.
That's not a good argument, Avery.
That's not a good No. No. Hold on. Hold
on. Don't run. Don't run. Don't run.
>> Answer the question or you're out of
here.
>> Why? Okay. What do you want?
>> Get off the stage.
>> Why? Okay. What do you want? No. Leave
me. What?
>> Absolute doororknob. Dumb.
>> No. No. I'm dick.